i want to do a stands for stains with
you
[Applause]
um what is your most frequent stain
dilemma
um my pants usually
because i just when i'm eating i'm a
little messy
um
in blood often sometimes yeah all right
that's good because we have blood out
here oh good good good today
i'm gonna try something for the first
time okay when you said blood i thought
hydrogen peroxide
so i'm going to actually learn on the
stands for stains with you
let's learn take a paper towel now
here's number one i want you to take it
and i want you to dab like a little
bunny like i want you to do that okay
and you want to dab the paper towel
because this is going to
it's lift lift we're lifting don't push
we're oh sorry and no not you i'm just
saying in general not yelling at you i'm
yelling at life
and anyone don't hesitate don't think
that stain's gonna get like oh it's
there it'll be fine in an hour you get
on that thing right now it's like a
woman that you don't want to lose from
like marrying you go after it yes you're
a bear you get that salmon
and so that is already
going to take off a top layer that you
will not have to contend with later
and
you know you just
this is important in the process of
stain removing
it's it's a layering technique don't
forget just don't question it and follow
not you life all right now we're going
to take a cotton pad and we're going to
blot it with the hydrogen peroxide all
right i think we have little beacons is
this hydrogen peroxide okay yeah
and you're gonna douse
all right and we're taking off the third
layer or are we doing something else a
second yeah and oh and you just go
in fact i i don't i this is
i i don't like oh
oh okay just go after it forget it
yes
all right do you see that oh my god i
read this i literally dreamt this up i
was like i i just know hydrogen peroxide
is going to get in there okay now this
is when you want to break out your tool
oh
but i don't think
i don't think we can on this television
show whip it out johnny
and get that brush out do you see how
the bristles work the magic and what's
important is you don't want to put a
colored soap a colored soap has dye in
it especially when you're working on a
white t-shirt type of surface and don't
get the sponge out and be careful with
the bristles because you'll break down
the fibers too much this is an art form
okay so this
they want a soft brush whip out that
soft brush
all right now what do you think is the
biggest change you've made in yourself
over the last decade like the number one
improvement my number one improvement um
i i try to have thought before action
and i'm no longer coloring my hair
you're a silver fox how's yours mine is
literally
i want to say proudly i believe it is
perfect
mine probably could
mine could still use a little love but
it's my first time
oh yeah interesting all right well this
is where
you literally watch out dump the bleach
out the bleach on it that's that's just
gonna murder the shirt and then and then
you
just stick it in the bath
put the baby right in the bath put the
baby in the bath the baby and the bath
i love that improvement pj that's a
really really good useful like life
skill it's a pretty basic one that i i
was ashamed i didn't even know people
did
um
it was mostly first thought best thought
one thing that i love about you
is that you tell us all
to make life a big old apple and take
the juiciest delicious bite out of it
thank you for that thank you drew
what whoa i don't even know where the
stain was
all right johnny knoxville jackass
forever oh my god
you need this
we all need this i've seen it so many
times now and i'm not keep watching
that's right i'm gonna keep watching it
it opens in theaters nationwide today
[Applause]
[Music]